hey je suis la mauvaise personne demande je sais mais
c'est le truc tu vois je suis la mauvaise
personne demande qu'est ce que c'est
je pense va te faire [ __ ] vas te
faire [ __ ]  ça ne me fait pas me
sentir gêné par mon mariage eh bien ma
chance ma femme est assise
juste là ouais je peux venir je ne
connais même pas le gars d'accord quel est ton 40
quel est mon P ouais quel est ton point que
dis-tu  cracher oh tu dis
bien qu'est-ce que tu dis tu dis l'amour
c'est ce salut oui oui le genre d'amour
dont je parle c'est absolu
le genre d'amour dont je parle
toi n'est-ce pas  essayer de tuer des gens
qu'est-ce que tu penses que tout le monde là-bas a
besoin de le voir déclarer forfait Ozzy oui qui
es-tu
j'ai envoyé ma fille Oh ta fille
Wow c'est incroyable vous ne vous ressemblez pas du
tout que faites-vous
c'est ma sœur à coup sûr et  parle-t-elle
et parle-t-elle oui, elle peut
même s'asseoir ou rester ou se retourner si vous
avez des nutriments hé bienvenue à bord Mike
Th  ank Toi capitaine je suis Mike au fait oh
je sais qui tu es je t'ai vu en
serre chaude au Geffen tu es super
merci ton cul est super trop
sérieux tu vois c'était juste moi Larry
Larry c'est la chérie du théâtre don'  ne
pas être si gêné